>> FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JIM COMEY
EXPOSED TODAY FOR BEING A LIAR,
EXPOSED TODAY FOR BEING A LIAR, A LEAKER, AND HE’S ALWAYS BEEN A
A LEAKER, AND HE’S ALWAYS BEEN A
WIMP.
OUR NEXT GUEST KNEW COMEY LONG
BEFORE THE DAYS OF INFAMY.
HE HIRED HIM AS THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK IN 1987.
JOINING ME NOW, RUDY G., NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR.
PERSONAL ATTORNEY.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET INTO.
BUT WHAT’S THE PERSONAL TAKEAWAY
FROM THIS REPORT WHICH IS
EXCEEDINGLY DETAILLED.
UNLIKE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL’S
REPORT, WELL WRITTEN.
>> I THINK THIS REPORT, FORGET
IF IT’S A CRIME OR NOT, SORT OF
DETAILS THE WORST DIRECTOR IN
THE HISTORY OF THE FBI.
>> IN THE HISTORY OF THE FBI.
>> JAY EDGAR HOOVER PUT HIM
ASIDE, WHATEVER HE DID, THIS
GUY, HE BROKE EVERY RULE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HOROWITZ
REPORT, HE BROKE EVERY RULE OF
THE FBI.
NOW, I THINK HE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
IF YOU -- IF YOU DON’T THINK HE
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED, OKAY.
BUT FOR HIM TO SAY I DIDN’T
LEAK.
THE REPORT DEMONSTRATES THAT HE
LEAKED.
HE’S COMPLETELY LYING TODAY.
I DIDN’T LIE, THE REPORT
DEMONSTRATES HE LIED.
IT JUST -- THEY’RE GIVING HIM A
BREAK.
THEY’RE BASICALLY SAYING, OH,
YOU KNOW, WE SHOULDN’T
PROSECUTE, NOT ENOUGH EVIDENCE.
BUT HE LIED, HE LEAKED, HE’S A
DISREPUTABLE HEAD OF THE FBI.
HE’S A DISGRACE TO THE FBI.
HE USED IT FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES, THE REPORT
DEMONSTRATES ALL OF THAT.
>> Laura: CLAPPER WAS ON CNN
TONIGHT, DID ANYONE ASK HIM A
QUESTION ABOUT IT?
>> I’M NOT SURE IF CLAPPER KNOWS
WHERE HE IS.
BRENNAN IS THE BRAINS, CLAPPER
IS THE IDIOT.
IF YOU WANT ME TO GUESS WHO
ORCHESTRATED THIS, CLAPPER IS
NOT CAPABLE.
I WON’T TELL YOU WHO I THINK
DID.
>> Laura: RUDY, WHAT COMEY SAID,
WHEN HE WAS ASKED THE REASON FOR
BRIEFING TRUMP BACK IN JANUARY
OF 2017 ON THAT PHONEY -- ON THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
>> IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR ME TO
ASSURE HIM WE WERE NOT
PERSONALLY INVESTIGATING HIM.
AND I DIDN’T WANT HIM THINKING I
WAS BRIEFING HIM ON THIS TO SORT
WAS BRIEFING HIM ON THIS TO SORTOF HANG IT OVER HIM IN SOME WAY.
OF HANG IT OVER HIM IN SOME WAY.I WAS BRIEFING HIM ON IT BECAUSE
I WAS BRIEFING HIM ON IT BECAUSEWE HAD BEEN TOLD BY THE MEDIA IT
WE HAD BEEN TOLD BY THE MEDIA IT
WAS ABOUT TO LAUNCH.
WE DIDN’T WANT TO KEEP THAT FROM
HIM.
AND I WAS KEEN NOT TO LEAVE HIM
WITH THE IMPRESSION THAT THE
BUREAU WAS TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING TO HIM.
>> Laura: BUT TODAY’S IG REPORT
SAYING WITNESSES INTERVIEWED BY
SAYS SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT
SAYING WITNESSES INTERVIEWED BY THE OIG, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
THE OIG, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
SAID THEY DISCUSSED TRUMP’S
POTENTIAL RESPONSES TO BE TOLD
ABOUT THE SALACIOUS RESPONSES
INCLUDING TRUMP MAKE STATEMENTS
ABOUT OR PROVIDE INFORMATION OF
VALUE TO THE PENDING RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE INVESTIGATION.
RUDY, IS THIS EVIDENCE THAT
COMEY AND FBI OFFICIALS WERE
TRYING TO UNDERMINE TRUMP.
>> 100%.
>> IF THERE’S A CONSPIRACY
INSIDE OF THAT DEPARTMENT, SET
HIM UP IN THE FIRST MEETING.
>> NUMBER ONE, A CLEAR
ENTRAPMENT.
100% CLEAR ENTRAPMENT BY COMEY
WHO, DESPITE HIS MORAL PROBLEMS,
IS A VERY SMART GUY.
UNLIKE MUELLER WHO IS LACKING IN
INTELLECT.
THIS GUY IS REALLY SMART.
HE WAS TRYING TO TRAP HIM LIKE
HE TRAPPED FLYNN.
>> Laura: JUST LIKE IT.
>> TRYING TO TRAP.
>> Laura: YOU’RE NOT A TARGET.
>> YOU’RE NOT A TARGET, IT’S
OKAY.
I HAVE THE THING IN MY BAG BUT
I’M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU AND
I’LL INDICT YOU, HORRIBLE THING
TO DO.
ANY REPUTABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD
BE DISGRACED BY THAT.
HE WAS TRYING TO TRAP THE
PRESIDENT.
IT’S DISINGENEROUS FOR HIM TO
MAKE THE STATEMENTS NOW.
BUT WHO KNOWS WHAT THE LIBERAL
MEDIA IS GOING TO DO WITH THIS.
BUT THIS GUY IS DISGRACED IN THE
EYES OF ANY FBI AGENT.
THEY TRAILS, THIS -- THEY
REALIZE THIS IS WORSE THAN
ANYTHING THAT J. EDGAR HOOVER
DID.
WHEN HE WALKED IN AND THE
PRESIDENT WAS THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND FACED HIM
WITH THAT, HE WAS TRYING TO TELL
HIM, I HAVE SOMETHING ON YOU SO
YOU BETTER KEEP ME IN OFFICE.
HE EVEN REALIZED HE WAS GOING
TO DO IT.
THERE ARE STATEMENTS THAT MADE
IT CLEAR THAT HE WAS GOING TO
EXTORT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I HOPE THEY PROSECUTE HIM ON THE
LAST ONE.
>> Laura: THE FISA.
>> THIS GUY SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
THIS IS THE GUY -- PEOPLE SHOULD
REALIZE, HE’S THE GUY THAT PUT
MARTHA STEWART IN JAIL ON A --
>> Laura: AN HIS LAWYER WENT
AFTER CONRAD BLACK.
>> IN ORDER TO GET PUBLICITY.
THE MARTHA STEWART CASE IS A
JOKE.
I DON’T KNOW MARTHA STEWART
PARTICULARLY.
SHE’S ATTACKED PRESUMPTUOUS.
I SAID AT THE TIME, THIS IS A
PUBLICITY STUNT BY HIM.
>> Laura: POPOVER.
>> YEAH, THAT’S WHAT HE DID.
>> Laura: WHOSE CONDUCT WAS MORE
EGREGIOUS AND DAMAGING TO THE
INTEGRITY UNDER THE RULE OF LAW,
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE RULE OF
LAW, MIKE FLYNN AND THE SETUP
AND HER AGENTS OR WHAT JIM COMEY
DID FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS.
>> EVERYTHING REVEAL IN
HOROWITZ’S REPORT SHOULD BE LIKE
A TEACHING MANUAL FOR THE FBI.
DON’T EVER DO THIS AGAIN.
>> Laura: DOESN’T THE LYING
PROSECUTOR.
>> IF J. EDGAR HOOVER WAS UP
UNTIL NOW THE WORST DIRECTOR,
THIS GUY HAS GONE WAY BEYOND.
>> Laura: HE CLAIMED -- THE
THING THAT GETS ME, RUDY, AS A
FIRST-YEAR ASSOCIATE AT A LAW
FIRM IN DC, WE KNEW BASIC RULES
OF ETHICS AS YOUNG LAWYERS.
YOU GO TO THE DEPARTMENT AS A
FIRST-YEAR PROSECUTOR.
YOU HAVE SPENT THE WEEK DOING
ETHICS REVIEW.
YOU KNOW IT.
HE CLAIMS IT WASN’T A FEDERAL
RECORD, A SENSITIVE FEDERAL
RECORD.
HE CLAIMS HIS MEMO TO THE FILE
WASN’T A RECORD.
THAT DOESN’T PASS THE STRAIGHT
FACE TEST, DOESN’T IT?
THAT’S A LIE.
>> EVERYBODY WILL THINK I’M
MAKING THIS UP.
I’M DISGUSTED WITH JIM COMEY.
I HAVE BEEN FOR OVER A YEAR.
THIS IS DISGRACEFUL.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS CRAZY
ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA.
>> Laura: WHY AREN’T THEY MADE.
THEY WERE LEFT DOWN THE GARDEN
PATH TOO.
>> A DISGRACEFUL PROSECUTOR.
HE’S EVERYTHING THEY’VE BEEN
AGAINST FOR YEARS.
THE OUT OF CONTROL PROSECUTOR
WHO PROSECUTES PEOPLE FOR HIS
OWN AMBITION, THIS GUY IS A
DISGRACE.
LEFT OR RIGHT, HE’S A DISGRACE.
AND HE’S VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Laura: BUT THE NOBLE GOAL
THAT HE AND McCABE AND STR
AVERAGES CK.
>> YOU CAN DO ANYTHING -- YOU
CAN LIE, YOU CAN CHEAT, YOU CAN
TRY TO GET MANAFORT TO LIE.
13 TIMES YOU PUT HIM IN SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
YOU BRING HIM, GET WISEMAN, A
TOTAL ANIMAL TO GO AFTER HIM.
PERFECTLY OKAY.
IF IT WERE A TERRORIST, THEY
WOULD GO CRAZY.
BUT EQUAL RIGHTS.
>> Laura: GIVE HIM HIS RIGHTS,
SQUARE MEALS.
>> IT INCLUDES TRUMP AND THE
TERRORISTS.
>> Laura: UNBELIEVABLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> BEING A LAWYER --
>> Laura: I’M SO GLAD I’M A
LAWYER.
OH, MY GOD, DRIVES ME CRAZY.
YOU’D BE FIRED AS A FIRST-YEAR
ASSOCIATE IF YOU DIDN’T KNOW
PROPER DOCUMENT HANDLING IN A
LITIGATION, A CIVIL LITIGATION,
LET ALONE BEING A PROSECUTOR AND
RELEASING INFORMATION DURING
YOUR TENURE OR AFTER.
>> 100%, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: THIS IS BASIC ETHICS
101, A CIVIL LAWYER, CRIMINAL
LAWYER, OR PROSECUTOR.
THIS KIND OF STUFF IS JUST --
CNN, SHAME ON YOU FOR NOT